today's topic we're going to be doing
another episode of moment of truth
oh wow i was not ready i mean last
episode was pretty
juicy it's not juice it was apple
cider vinegar
let's go let's get it angela simny is a
27 year old interior designer from
tahunga california
she has been married to her husband for
two years she was asked over 50
questions by a polygraph examiner
21 have been chosen for tonight angela
simny
this is your moment of truth
[Applause]
i'm david angela's husband i'm lucille
angela's mom
hi i'm eva angela's best friend question
one
do you believe that most women are
jealous of your beauty
what first attracted you to your husband
um you know what we met on the internet
and he came to my front door and i
opened the door
and looked straight out and had to look
up he's six foot four
i had an instant thing for him
give me two seconds all right just give
me what you can't handle these cliches
se tu se tu
what got you was ching
yo why you mad ah damn
why are you mad at her i'm not mad at it
i'm just saying
seto yeah when you know it's the six
foot master race
open them legs wide facto
that's it question two
would it bother you if your future
children inherited your husband's
red hair
[Music]
i'm gonna have to say yes
that's not even a low blow that's that's
but then again that's the first
questions
i don't know i feel like for some people
like the ginger part of them is part of
who they are
it'd be like if he was with somebody and
then they were
like asian like would you bother if your
kids had your
your my wife's your wife's asian
features
it's not exactly the same thing but
whatever it's not how's it not
um it's just because
ginger is it's because it's ginger this
is ginny yeah cause it's ginger it's
really close
they don't have feelings they do
you know what's funny i'm just remember
when ariel was gonna be a black girl who
you remember when ariel was gonna get
black girl a lot of ginger's like yo
what about ginger representation
they was mad because they don't get
enough redheads on tv and i get them
i get them i get them but they do though
do they they do i think of like what
mary jane
ariel who else eric cartman who's that
who's that is that the fact that
hey you brought ariel in there out of
three characters and one of them is like
a fat man who's
your first character was a was it was a
mermaid something that don't exist
yeah but did you see when she got them
legs
no it's not just not my thing hey hey
hey a whole new world
is that relative okay the [ __ ] out of
here
under the sea thank you
question three would you respect your
husband
more if he made more money
um you know
um i'm gonna have to say yes
that answer is
true
[Music]
how do you feel about that last answer
[Applause]
i'm good i'm fine i went yeah yeah
yeah that's that is that cheese huh i'm
good
yeah it's fine me it's
like you know huh
what you say about me i mean i'm not i'm
not crying bro and just uh because of my
just i mean do you like
yeah the further the further they lean
their head back huh
i'm not bothered huh
make me think of that donald trump
would you say it is sometimes a struggle
to stay faithful to your husband
you know my uh my husband has a job
where it takes him out of the country
an awful lot so my answer would be yes
that answer is
true that's like oh
oh yeah okay the money was one thing but
it'd be
like that rough and you would be more
attracted to me if i made more money
but then the more i travel the harder
you'll find it to be
faster so it was really just so the more
and more we're gonna go down this rabbit
hole because a rabbit hole it is
okay follow the rat rabbit the the more
and more we're gonna we're just gonna
find out that she
she's really just with him because he's
tall it's not because of the looks
it's not because of the hair it's not
because of the money it's really because
you know long term but other than that
have you ever done something while your
husband was away on business
that you feel guilty about
you got ken parsons over here looking at
her like
i'm single i would die to go with your
husband
if you ever what whoa whoa
you think she would sleep with her best
friend's husband no she's just i'm
pretty sure she thinks he's a good man
but you don't think she would do that i
don't know i don't know her okay
i i i'm gonna get to guess no i wouldn't
know i wouldn't guess
but you have to guess right now for the
people no i don't i don't have to guess
i wouldn't know
i'm just saying that because i think
it's fun it's a funny situation in my
head
but in the in the in the face and the
face was really just like
wheeling back wheeling back to like one
time she's looking she was staring at me
no no no there's something there look at
no you can't you can't you can't
subtitle it
and then expect me not to be influenced
by that okay
okay okay we'll be back i'm not going to
say hey hey hey you guys leaving the
comments
back well priest huh
yes
that answer is is it just me does she
not seem like she's enjoying it when she
delivers these like
cold answers she looks at him she goes
like it's revenge
true look at her
[Music]
see i did that
was is she trying to get back to this
listen
you know and that's what i think i told
you that last
last time you know what the [ __ ] you get
yourself into yes
this this this this tv show is wrong
but you know what the if this is some
revenge kind of
this is the mother the mother they got
in there
okay they already resent them they man
they already
already gave up it's already over in the
head
so yes the show is bad but the person
that's going to sign up to this
is already over they want to get back to
this [ __ ] i'm just saying
and you know why she's doing this to him
because this man is struggling where it
really matters
the bedroom and that's why this episode
is sponsored by bluechu
bluechu gives you the first chewable
with the same
fda approved active ingredients as vagra
or
cialis it's prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor and wait in line and
it's even
cheaper than a pharmacy and they prepare
it and ship it right to you
in a discreet package so you don't have
to worry about nobody coming through
like oh what's that
and you don't even have to leave your
house which during these times let's be
honest
so right now we got a special promo guan
visit bluechew.com
and use promo code abba and get your
first shipment
free in the end i don't think any of you
want to end up on the moment of truth
confused by why
your wife your significant other is
putting you on blast like that but if
you had some blue chew in your life you
know what i mean
maybe you wouldn't be chewing on your
teeth while she putting you on blast
in front of all your homies handle your
business in private
and business gonna be handled in public
blue chew
doing y'all the necessary service angela
have you ever hooked up
with any of my former boyfriends
[Applause]
the answer is yes
told you that look oh
if you oh you yeah you trifle
that's what it was i'll give it to you
okay you guessed it
i was right question 11
have you ever thought about hiring a
private investigator
to follow your husband around
did you see the did you see the lips
did you see the lid
a private investigator [ __ ] let's go
hasn't yes this is confirmed
listen people people people people
let me talk to the people them all right
people
it is confirmed like a don king perm
that she wants to get back at this man
she's resenting this dude
but i don't know what happened i don't
know what it is i do not know what it is
but this is the proof who has it it's
like she's
excusing herself from do you understand
what i'm saying
when your husband goes on tour with rock
bands do you ever suspect that he is
cheating on you
yes have you ever given a reason to
suspect that you might be cheating
i don't think so but i mean she always
asked me oh
do you see any hot girls today and it's
not like okay here we go
okay he should be on the hot seat
because he's lying he's lying
what do you mean he's lying he's lying i
have reason
i do yeah that's what i'm saying
she's getting back at him for okay
peep game there's something about women
wanting to have proof of what's
happening
right she can't prove it so i'm gonna
get back at you
on the i think that's what the dynamic
is but then again
um
whatever
you have 12 truthful answers i
look at me okay i know you want a
hundred thousand dollars
i want to give you a hundred thousand
dollars there's an answer you can give
to this question
that could be devastating to your
marriage i want it
even if it means ruining your marriage
you want to talk about not giving up
that's not giving a [ __ ] no she didn't
hesitate
yo the thing was over before the the
show
started she knows exactly what the hell
she doing like stop it knock it off
at this point the way she said it the
delivery
the delivery come on now come on come on
have you ever regretted marrying your
husband
[Music]
[Applause]
you seem a little shocked david was
there anything you want to say
i like how the bombs just like like a
tear in the headlights
is very like i don't know
it's very awkward there it really
doesn't feel like uh
wow it really feels like last
thanksgiving when my turkey was dry
it's kind of awkward isn't it you know
what it makes me think of you know those
italian moms whose sons are like
mobsters and killers and they're
oblivious to everything they're like
oh is that a little bit of blood how did
you get that they know they don't
have you ever regretted marrying your
husband
yes that answer is
[Music]
she knows what she's doing and doing it
to the end
this is revenge it's what it is you
can't be straight
and the way she she's looking at him
okay do you do you regret
marrying your husband yes and she looks
at him like yeah
yeah yeah all them girls on tour i got
things on you i can't prove it
but yeah you know what i'm talking about
she doesn't give her yeah
it's i don't know what happened between
them i do not know
but this is payback for one hundred
thousand dollars would you pose nude in
an adult magazine
lucille i'm wondering how you would feel
the furniture was yes
i don't believe it will be for one
hundred thousand dollars would you pose
newt in an adult magazine i need your
answer yes or no
no that answer is
false
[Applause]
i mean y'all surprised that the shallow
no
it's shallow
water is not wet true
i just couldn't imagine being so mad and
angry at somebody that you'd want to
drag them on television
and do all this extra stuff like that
that's not the level is a petty
you know me are over nine thousand the
levels of petty
over ten thousand like if you want to
force just divorce what's all this
i'd rather you go for my neighborhood i
see what it is and that's what i would
rather someone cheated on me
and wasted my time with all this if she
gets a divorce she just get a divorce
but at least
if she gets a divorce at least she gets
the chance to get
half a male or whatever the hell true
she probably told that
the moment of truth and you're like yo
we got you girl we got you
yeah yeah absolutely because
especially and i think that if she would
answer
this question now in 2020 whatever
she would say yes because now in the 90s
it was a different thing it was viewed a
different way yeah
yeah right but if she would have they
would ask her the question now and she
would be like yeah
shallow it's all good you know i mean
she would random with it right but
yeah it's just at least we said it she's
shallow
right so also vindictive yeah vindictive
very very addictive to bear someone like
on like on television if i'm going to
get
a divorce at least i'm going to get
something out of it my own money will
you embarrassed yourself herself
yeah definitely because that she doesn't
get nothing yet
i don't know maybe it's just me but
listen if i'm gonna break up or not
something's good i want in on the best
terms possible
i couldn't imagine wanting to drag him
through the mud because you know i'm
hurt or i feel like i was betrayed i
don't know it's just weird to me so
maybe i feel that way you know the whole
money thing is
one of the intro would you respect him
if you made more money ah
you know just the levels of uh
would i respect my girl more if she had
bigger titties what
it was that's what it is would you
respect your goal like what does the
respect have to do with how much i don't
know
that's what it is but it's just like
it's accomplished
if if you think about i'm trying to play
devil's advocate here
but if you try to put it in certain ways
it's like you know
my girl doesn't respect me more because
i have more money
right she respect me more because i'm
happy with what i'm doing
i'm i'm i'm doing a lot of things and
i'm successful in what i'm doing right
and the byproduct of that is me
having more money that is in someone
that is a good person
i believe my girl is a good person i'm
inclined to agree right
but if a person is shallow that same
sentiment
in someone that is shallow would be more
money
more money you know whatever girl's like
tomorrow's like me and you moment of
truth
no i'm not going i'm not doing it i'm
not subjecting myself to that
i'm not doing it i don't want to see her
answer the questions preach
what do you think her answer is going to
be i don't give a i'm out of this
so you guys know what the moral of the
story today is um just don't date
hairdressers
[Music]
i